indy 500 is the only thing i've done in
my life
the more i've done it the more it meant
to me most things you become
more sort of used to not bored with
that's the wrong thing but you become
almost a bit numb to them
even if it's jumping out of an airplane
yeah you're like i've done it five times
indeed i slept less and less every year
i
focused harder i worked harder um
but that that to me especially now and
you'll get to
experience it now doing the tv stuff
there the pre-race
when they sing back home again in
indiana all that stuff that we couldn't
allow ourselves to enjoy as drivers
yeah i get goosebumps thinking about
that was that to me
i love that place and i love that event
um
it's so special
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
on the show today is the lovely dario
franchitti
daario was my teammate back in the
indycar days and you'll end up hearing
about him being my favorite teammate
he's a four-time series champion he is a
three-time indy 500 champion
i think i should just start interviewing
all the drivers because there's
um such a resonance understanding and
respect
and gets so much deeper when we can go
into these
conversations which we just never took
time to do when we were racing against
each other so we talked about
you know tons about that life after you
know aspects of you know everything from
his daughter racing to you know jimmy
johnson
getting into indy cars and um you know
funny stories about you know back in the
day
so really really great time with dario
and
um really grateful for the time i hope
you have a have a good time listening to
us
uh reminisce thanks for doing this no
worries
are you in scotland or no you're in
london right i'm a london shower yeah
yeah all the um london shire what's
london shire
no it's just it's like england fire it's
um
what's england shire it's um
just how we sort of refer to it
sometimes
yeah but i'll be yeah i didn't learn
that slang
it was a while ago come on i mean it was
but i would have remembered london shire
england shire
i actually kind of felt like i could
learn a little scottish which is like a
whole another language
accents were kind of quieter it's kind
of
softening again into like england shire
versus
[Applause]
is that because ellie has such a perfect
english accent
she's a bit posh isn't she she is posh
she's super posh
yeah i think she went to elocution
lessons at one point
sorry what so they teach you how to talk
top proper like me like
wow like where you learn how to put your
legs
when you sit in a chair and where to put
your silverware is it like a
uh etiquette uh were you going to see
how you put your legs when you sit in a
skirt
i suppose i would with a kill
when you wear a kilt do you wear it the
way you're supposed to wear it
as in the whole like the situation
you've got to
you really have to does it feel good
it depends how cold it is
if it's i'd normally wear it in scotland
so it's a little it can be a little
but it's kind of liberating you know
yeah you get this
walk on you're sort of walking i don't
know anybody wears a kill
there's a certain walk that i don't walk
like unless i'm wearing a kill and i
think
i think it's going to kill i don't think
it's the fact that
you know everything's hanging out grab
this walk then
what's the difference in this walk
can you find your maybe wearing a skirt
did you
walk more feminine no it's actually the
opposite
it's actually it's more of a sort of a
bit of attitude a bit of a sway
um counter balance feminine energy of
the skirt
no i it's not honestly you're a kilt
what i would have killed
if it's more the opposite you feel quite
sort of
um not aggressive but you're like
i'm gonna kill you know you're getting
sort of very scottish pride and
um and let's be honest most of the
places i would have killed
you're the only person in the room and i
killed and it's
you know so it's more about the it's
more about the
um what is it tartan what is the tartan
yeah
tartan it's more about sort of the pride
of the tartan than it is about having no
no no pants on underneath the kilt
pants or underwear yes you can see
that's an important distinction to i got
confused with that one in america
they're going oh yeah blah blah blah
taking my pants off for me i would just
hang on there a second
it was uh you know one of my teammates
no no no
no but have you ever noticed how bad it
is to walk in
nobody looks cool walking in a racing
suit because of the shoes
you think you wish you had heels on no
just shoes you could actually walk in
without sort of
you know you feel like i don't know i
never felt comfortable and feel like
slippers it's just that i was
mine a size too small as well so maybe
that was the problem
why did you try your shoes on in the
first place when you were cold
no i had to to get to fit them in the
car you wouldn't have had this problem
like to fit in the car i had to wear
a size one what should you wear not
massive 44
10 13 15 us 10 no
basketball player no
but yeah the bigger shoe that feeling
when you would go in the braking zone
and you go for the brake pedal and you
hit the top of the tub
didn't have to happen too many times
before i put small shoes on
yeah you don't really want to screw up
those kinds of things
so i saw a video i think i don't
remember if it's you
or ellie posted of um sophia
at silverstone looking at the lights
yeah she sounds super by the way she
sounds super posh too
um so she's uh five she's five
five and um but the end of it of course
is what
i was the most interested in when she
said she wanted to come back and go real
fast
yeah thanks dad what do you think of
that
i think in those situations i think of
you and i think of your dad and i'm like
okay because she is she's got that
energy she's like
she and she the whole thing the thing i
didn't film
was when we drove onto the circuit and
she looked over and said daddy
what are we doing and it was a christmas
display it was christmas lights for
anybody that hasn't seen it so what are
you doing
so we're going to see the christmas
lights don't give it daddy we're on the
racetrack
yeah but with christmas lights is the
speed limit daddy no no i want to go
fast i'm here to go fast so we
i said well we can't well that's not
very good is it and she was having a
proper
kickoff so i had to promise i was going
to take her to
the track next summer and uh
and take her for a spin what about a
go-kart dad
no come on seriously you are you against
it i don't know how i feel about it
because there's a part of me thinks that
who am i to say
no who am i to sort of because i mean
your dad my dad
your mom my mom did exactly the opposite
they encouraged us
as much as we wanted so i don't want to
say no
but
i don't know okay too much so you know
too much that's the thing right you know
how hard it is you know all these
so what is it about that knowing that
makes you think
honey you don't because if you
it would be if it almost feels like
you're trying to say
um that you you know it's
it's really hard and you don't
understand you don't understand
so what is it that you understand that
makes you think ah
cause you freaking love racing you love
cars like i don't know if
i know anybody that loves racing cars
more than you
you might be right that's the thing i
love it and i love going to
and go to goodwood and and with with
ellie and the kids and mourinho and
holly and luca
um and just in sharing that experience i
love it
um i don't know if it's just
the sort of the just how difficult it is
and how
impossible and and um it can be and do
you know i think i'm gonna i'll allow
her to
do what you know i'll allow that to
wrong workers trust me she'll do exactly
what she wants to do
um but encourage her to try different
things
you know what is what what's her passion
she shouldn't do it because it's my
passion
and it was my but if it becomes her
passion then i think you can
you can't stop you know you can you
can't stop them ellie rode horses
so there's been some discussion of that
um
[Music]
which could be worse than horsepower
doesn't get more expensive than horses
and
horses
so hang on i want to go back into the
difficult thing because
obviously there's more there so when you
say
difficult like i get it we all get it's
hard right we get that
you know it's hard to get to the top of
anything whether you're
in sports or whether you're in business
i don't care right
so now i want to know what that heart
was like what do you
when you say hard what is the first
thing you think of
um
to me it was well those are a couple of
things came straight to mind
those early years um
that were you know when didn't
necessarily have the funds to go racing
and the distress that that put on
myself the whole family that kind of
thing that was
i mean that was that was not good um
and then i think in my particular case
all the different injuries
and that sort of um the damage that that
did so
those are those are the two things um
basically
it is odd because i love you know i love
a challenge and
i can't think of anything better than
being passionate about something and
challenging yourself every day that's
that's what i still do but i think it's
more just trying to protect
sophia valentina afterwards but
um you know that's just the sort of i
guess trying to find balance as a parent
which is
protect her from protector from the pain
protector from
disappointment from failure are you
trying to give her are you trying to
give her a ribbon every time she goes
and does something dad
no like because you know you know the
failures of where you learn right
i mean you know that absolutely and i
know this and that's you know that's you
know with any of the guys i work with
any of the drivers that's what
you know i preach all the time um it's
just she's five and she's little and
she's cute and
you know her little sister's two and
she's equally cute and
even smaller you just kind of want to
protect them and
uh you know you you knew me
at my sort of most intense
period in my life when i was absolutely
tunnel vision
um and it's sort of you know there's
maybe a different side to
to life that i've discovered and it's um
it's wonderful but it's also
bloody scary the new side
the other side the additional side the
at the side that you couldn't okay tell
me about that side
well you know i never wanted i never
when i was driving i didn't want kids um
and ashley and i talked about that like
now
that was just never a plan um and i was
so everything took second place to my
what i did
i get it the schedule wins the whatever
it all went it i get it i get it
i mean you lived it equally as i did
everything comes second and
you know that that's great but it's
it it's wonderful trust me i loved it i
loved every minute of what i got to do
you know this this other part is sort of
more about life is uh
it's i'm so fortunate that i've got to
do
life in these stages and this this sort
of uh
you know i found myself for 42 years old
having my
my first kid which is kind of cool
what's the scary you said scary didn't
you
you said this other part of life that
it's scary what is that uh
well it's scary because i sort of that
intensity's
kind of backed off a lot and i want to
sort of again protect
my my kids and
find a balance be a i mean one of the
sort of big three worries i guess has
been
you want to be you want to be a great
parent you want to not mess them up you
don't want to
wrap them and cut rule but then you
don't want to you know
push them too hard what's that you know
where's the balance and
um you know funny enough i've talked to
your dad about this
really yeah yeah we talked about it
indie work because he was laughing at me
get ready and i'm thinking i hear you
so we talked a little bit about that you
know and then
well just the sort of let them
do what they want to do you know
encourage
them push them if they want if that's
just you know
you've got it as you say you've got to
go and experience these things
i guess what i would say because you
know if you talk to my dad
and i'm guessing that there was a
conversation around
how he did it even and you know you know
how your life went like we've had great
lives but
um it wasn't without it's
inevitable necessary balancing that
needed to happen and realizations that
were
you know um needing you know attention
in areas that were out of balance
and that's for sure been my journey
especially in the last few years
um so so i guess like dad didn't by the
way dad didn't have the answer
and like you don't have the answer and
no one has the perfect answer for their
kid
right and every parent is probably going
to
give them some level of trauma whether
it's you love them too much or you don't
love them enough like right just
something simple like that
and um that really
the balance even though you want to give
it to them
[Music]
you're not them she's going to have to
learn it for herself
and part of that learning might come
from
a tremendous imbalance that highlights
something that she needs to give
attention to but you got to
let her follow her flow so again dad so
it's almost like
like step back and let her do because
she's got to figure it out for herself
anyway and i know this trust me i know
all this and i'm you know as you say
the thing about balance and life i know
this but it's just
putting it at this point in in
in her life in valentina's life is
trying to put that into practice all
those things i know
and all those things i understand but
it's just yeah
it's just a little uh it's a little
moment
shall we say um and you know i joke
about it you're scary than driving in
some way
oh massively really
oh you know massively you're driving if
you make a mistake you know you might
crash
or you might you know whatever
yeah but if you do this and you mess it
up it's like
you know that's that's the tricky part
that's the bit
so you don't you don't want to mess it
up but um luckily ellie's a lot more
uh sort of on it i would say
so um yeah we'll figure it out
how does ellie balance you out
yeah absolutely she is a top bird by the
way
she's tall part she is she's so much fun
and she's so posh at the same time like
who created this amazing human that's
like so
put together and like smart
and uh you know well-dressed and
beautiful
and articulate and speaks the queen's
english
and then on the other hand is like who's
doing shots
exactly apart from having terrible taste
in
in men
no she she is top bloke don't worry
thanks dp yeah she she just
yeah that intensity that i had and she
sort of helped to
chill that out a bit you know and i i
can be quite introvert in a lot of ways
and she'll
you know she's the opposite and um she
has got a lot of patience
which is yeah as you know you know i'm
learning patients i've definitely
learned patience since
what year so were you still racing when
you met
we met at indy in 13. okay
so i was at the after party accident
what the
accident was 13 right in 13 end of 13
yeah so she was there and we
we kind of talked for a bit and i was
like
wow so you met her that year at night
yeah i was like hey and then she said oh
it's lovely to meet you
um maybe we'll see each other again and
if she's wait i went
you're a top bird you have to come back
around yeah exactly come chat and then
it was later that year was that was the
accident that made you have to retire
yes later that year that was october so
we met we met in may october
accident i eventually called her in
january
were you with it yet
there's a little out there blame that
she's like dario your head's still
scrambled
no yeah she's like you're uh yeah you're
a little old
um head injury and then we had our first
date in
june of the following year and that was
it
i want to go back to so i had this
question i wanted to ask you because
i get asked it all the time and i don't
know how to answer it
and um and it's not very often
that i get a chance to ask anyone this
question
that would be able to even add to
this concept this idea um and since you
have a daughter that is going to become
a race car driver perhaps maybe this is
something that you
um you put some thought to as you said
that it reminds you of
myself and my dad but i get asked all
the time
and i don't know if this is part of why
you also don't
aren't excited for her to race or not
maybe maybe not but i get asked all the
time what it's like to be a girl out
there and what was it like for me and
it's like
dude i can't answer that because i've
only ever been a girl like i don't know
what any other perspective is like
so you know i'm being a little bit
selfish right now but i'm
curious um what that what is that
what is what was your experience or what
was it like
from your perspective to be a girl
because you could you knew it from your
own standpoint as well as
other guys probably i don't know maybe
you guys talked about me maybe you
didn't
i don't know but so i mean i remember
the first time
we met so long it was
i think it was croft you just come over
and um
and literally after that i think the
next time we met was you were
racing atlantics so it was a you know
um and
then you came into indycar and it was
i got the feeling and it's getting
better
but i got the feeling with with most
drivers got the benefit of the doubt
of let's see how good they are where it
is i think when you came into indycar
there was sort of a hmm
nah twice why is um
wait show me what you've got you know
what i mean
um and there was a moment when
i certainly i was one of those okay
right let's
and then what what are you why are you
here what's your
you know and it was a qualifying for
indy
your first indianapolis 500 you went
honking down at term one
he turned in and the thing snapped
sideways and you can't be caught it
jumped straight back on the throttle and
did this
the other sort of 3.7 laps and i went
all right and that was like your that
was like you to to me and i think to a
lot of the other drivers
it was that was that okay
you were you sort of but that just for
that one moment you'd earned
your your place i think
and we and then from that point i mean
we were teammates we raced against each
other we had some
close calls i never thought about you
any differently than
every other of the 20
however many or 32 or 30 lunatics
in indianapolis um
the situation do you remember um
there was one time i was disciplined i
was disappointed that was my
the way i think about it you and dan had
a bit of an argument
at milwaukee milwaukee
oh yeah yeah i do i i was
going going into turn one and he sort of
chopped down on me and
put me like i ended up getting bumping
like we touched and i went
which anybody that knows open wheel
racing you don't really want to
touch wheels i'm i'm in the grass going
across the grass and one and two i
i come back on and anyway i was i was
having a great race because i think i'd
started like
last the car was so so hard to drive and
didn't qualify well and then
i'd made it up to like f i was passing
for fifth i feel like
on dan in the first stint which is about
80 laps
and um so i was holland
and he did that and then it obviously
ended up getting going all the way to
the back again and i think i maybe end
up finishing fifth or
eighth or something like that i came
back through but not you know
all the way and um and afterwards i was
so mad at him
and so i talked to my team and then i
saw him on pit lane and you know how it
is that the racetrack you don't
always have an opportunity to see
someone after the race like because you
ever
everybody gets done and then they leave
yeah and so i saw him and i was like
oh i'm gonna go over there i think i'm
maybe i even asked
it reminds me of the milka dunno
situation at um mid-ohio
i i a lot of times ask first like
can i go talk to him like i want to go
tell him who did you actually
really nobody really tells me no and so
i go over there and i put my arm around
his
around his shoulder are on his trap and
i'm squeezing his traps
so hard and i'm telling him what he did
to me
and i'm so angry and then you know
that's sort of
like the the moment and um
he i remember he kind of spoke down to
me a little
he acted like i was overreacting and
um you know maybe i was but um you know
it was a little condescending yeah from
my point i was
watching that i remember i think i was
back at the truck already or something i
water i watched a replay and i was like
that was the one time i was kind of like
you know what
i think i said to you afterwards i said
if that could have been me or tony
talking and doing that with dan he'd
punch this
but you put him in a position you were
giving it to him absolutely just
and he he couldn't react and that was
the one time i was like
you know what i mean so what am i so
have you ever been in a situation
with a driver where it where you were
like that angry
um oh yeah so then what happened
um we exchanged pleasantries
um
should i have been able to do that are
you saying that this is like why it was
you i think if i remember you were
actually sort of giving them a bit of
push
and stuff as well yeah and i was like
well
that was the difference because if i had
to push dw like that
he would have which we did have a moment
you know seven we had a bit of an
altercation but um
yeah so that was the only thing but
apart from that to you
whether you were teammates or on track
it was
from that moment in india it was like
yeah you just you're one of the
one of the drivers one of the um
[Music]
yeah that was a that was a big moment i
mean what's that 15 years ago
yeah 2005. i still remember it
no that's what's funny is that i i can
remember that too and i remember
thinking that it was going to make more
of a difference for me to have
done that than qualified on the poll
yeah agreed i think qualifying the poll
people would have found a way to say oh
it was because of x y or z
or whatever yeah whatever people do
you know to me you were always i mean
you were really the best teammate if i'm
being honest like you were my
favorite teammate you were i feel like
you see that tell the teammates
i do let me make sure i haven't said
that to you before um no
i it's true because um
something i think there was the the
the ability to drive similar cars i
thought you and i had similar styles
and we spoke the same language about the
car so that was super helpful
but you were also helpful and
you i felt like you genuinely
cared and it and at the at and for sure
all of your information was transparent
and if i asked the question and even
sometimes when i didn't ask the question
you wanted to help and that's not
a common trait because again i've been
me so i know what it's like with all the
teammates i've had
and not everyone made me feel like that
in fact not many made me feel like that
and so i want to say thank you
um and i also want to know why is that
where did that come from who like
there's like the questions that go
through my head are like
mom dad upbringing values
uh your own personal confidence because
i feel like in the end that makes a big
difference too like your own personal
confidence and
like the uh the sidebar of to me your
own personal confidence is like
your one-year contracts every year you
know like
who does one-year contracts every year
when you could have probably done a
five-year contract you know
and so that sort of just spoke volumes
about your confidence but
like tell me about you know what did
your mom teach you what'd your dad teach
you i mean i know your parents but like
this is a unique like when i talked to
kanan when i interviewed kanaan
such a fun because like we don't ever
talk about this stuff
we don't go into these details and these
backgrounds and this
these feelings and information and
history and childhood
but now's the now such a fun time to do
that especially when we're old and have
perspective
we i think we do have perspective and we
in our i think in most
jobs most businesses we don't talk about
that um
we just don't because it's like okay are
we quick no why are we not quick how do
we make it faster
it was not productive we weren't going
to make any cars go faster
by saying how did your mom raise you
exactly that was the sort of
you know although working with the
drivers now the psychology of it
and why people act certain ways is
really helpful
to getting performance from different
people whether it's
scott dixon or back with with tony again
this year with
with jimmy johnson who's my new rookie
he's he's quite good
um i'm curious about that
let's get to that i want to hear about
you first
so i mean you know my mum
um she is a human no my sister
um and i'm not i'm not
i'm not afraid of a strong woman that
way you know my bro my
your mom's your sister is the oldest of
three so it's my sister's oldest
marina and marino who's younger so
my my both my grandmothers um
[Music]
you know incredibly strong women so
that's
i've never felt um towards the word i've
never sort of had
sort of a nervousness about it i love i
love stronger my
you know both ashley now ellie
incredibly strong women so um i think
that was part of the
um you know oh
so i mean guys occasionally oh you you
got beaten
by danica today i said yeah and i got
beaten by five other people
so that to me there was never a
difference
um and so as teammates i always felt
if we were all better
if if we could there was this a a rising
tide lifts all
boats right yeah and that was the way i
always looked at it and i still do
um you know whether that was the the
the andretti green years um whether that
was
with with scott dixon at the chippenham
race thing we we did that and i still do
that today in my and my job with
with um you know those guys in it sort
of
it and i i can i get a buzz now out of
when i can help
um when i can help with other drivers
that the drivers that i work with but i
remember i think it was mid-ohio you
qualified on the front row
[Music]
mm-hmm yeah
this goes to a concept i have because
you're such a nostalgic sort of like
you know goodwood festival and like i
have this idea that people are either
futurists and live in the future and get
attached to outcomes
or they kind of have sort of a past
orientation
which includes really good memory
because you know it's that sort of like
you you you you're in the feeling of the
memories and this
nostalgia the vibe the energy and so
it's kind of no surprise to me actually
because i actually have that written
down for some ideas to ask you about i'm
like
you're so nostalgic you're so you're
such an old soul
i'm i'm sitting here looking at the
pictures i've got um i've got pictures
i'm from my office
and this is my this is not the big silly
office with all the helmets and stuff in
it but
um the pictures of my old dog um
elliot sofia valentina and then it's all
like old racing cars and old
yeah you know a nice
yeah yeah yeah i mean you have great
memory
so your mom was super strong obviously
that they gave you a comfort which is
unique because some people
sometimes the strength um can be a
little out of balance and can
create sort of an apprehension to being
in a position where they feel like
they're being dominated or controlled by
a woman so
that to me says that you're you know
your family has a really balanced
female energy i would say it's a
partnership isn't it it's like marriage
it's a partnership there's not there
shouldn't be one dominant there's always
going to be
different days but it should sort of go
around a center as you said earlier
balance
i used to have this fantastic austrian
trainer
tony when he would you know i was like
sort of humpty dumpty and
break myself into a million bits and he
would sort of help put me back together
but he was very much
balanced life is about balance and he
always used to or she would say balance
violence life is about balance so true
what about george your dad see i feel
like george is just so
balanced
so you know when your dad at his
absolute when he's properly at the track
and he was having a bad day you know
oh god he was the worst i mean people
thought he'd end my career because he'd
get so fired up
right that was my dad at the car track
same level of yeah that same level of
just you know he wanted it so badly for
for his kids that he lost all reasoning
as
a lot of parents do but when i started
racing cars he went
the first meeting with um david leslie
jr and senior that i'd raced my first
races with
and he said something to them like okay
i've taken him as far as he
can go as far as i can you know more
than i do
and from that day he never commented
he never got involved and that was you
know
he was if almost every race my whole
career from that point
third what was that could have been 20
seconds just started playing golf
basically
he just started playing golf and he the
only time he commented one day i asked
for it i was like
that wasn't very i'd screwed up
somewhere and him and i were leaving the
track
i looked over that wasn't very good
today that was he said
no son you've had better days
[Laughter]
wait i'm i'm so fascinated by this
transition and how
you know gosh i'm only only your dad
could have taught my dad how to do that
um it's taken a lot longer for him to
calm down
um but uh did you guys ever talk about
that
not really you know i listened to you
one of
what your your podcast for your dad as
soon as i saw that i was like oh
this is this is going to be good so
whatever i was doing stop it and i just
and i watched and i listened and
um oh it was so much fun and you could
you were sort of
made me laugh because you're trying to
get your dad to help you because
you've become really deep since you've
retired you've become so
deep and you're trying to pillow dj n
and he's having none of it he's like
yeah well you know
just what we did and he was every time
you're trying to send him
i know he's like people love that
interview too they just like
i was trying so hard to get my dad to
get emotional and
crack and admit things and realize
things and have epiphanies and
break open and he's just like man
whatever it is whatever and i'm like
went back to work and that's just like
that's awesome but that's the kind of
thing my dad does it's like you sort of
have these moments
[Music]
two big things i feel like for you were
your flips in 2007 that
um obviously
had created a shift in you
of what you were i don't know maybe it
was fear-based a little bit
um i'm i'm and especially because having
lost greg moore which is a great friend
and
um you know dan hadn't passed yet but
obviously those are pretty traumatic
things and then of course the trauma of
nascar
the so um but the
but but in 2007 you know and of course
the first one that happened
was you know i'm being the good teammate
with you and i think i'm third and i'm
right behind you going down the back
straight straightaway at michigan
and dan is i didn't even know what this
was then he was trying to side draft i
think he said
and like i didn't even know what that
was so it was like what the heck is side
drafting it's a nascar term
um so you know you don't side draft in
an open wheel car
and so anyway he's trying to side draft
you
and anyway you guys you guys interlocked
and you flipped right over the top of me
it was the most creepy thing because i
went around three and four
and i didn't see a single car i came out
of four and i was like
i was looking you see that i went for
the rear view mirror up
um i looked in the rearview mirror and
there was nobody coming and i'm like
oh my god and so and then the one
the one at kentucky where i it was a
checkered flag and i think you weren't
sure it was the checkered flag
so you kept your foot in it and you
flipped what was it
uh was one of those jobs
and you launched and flipped all uh you
know
totally airborne and flipped over so
anyway what the hell happened
like what was your what was your what
was your break down there
so i was there was a sort of a school of
thought at the time that i decided to go
to nascar because of those flips
and that i would have thought i would
have thought that yeah that was not the
case
um it was money then yeah
you like money too you're like yeah you
know i'm scottish
you know these cars were by themselves
no no ferraris don't buy themselves
that's right i was i i had to have a new
challenge
that's what it was i'd won the 500
and i i was looking like i had a good
chance of winning the championship i
needed a new challenge i've done it for
10 years
um greg had passed away you know three
years into that
and i had had a massive accident that
started 2000 where i
really damaged my brain was that the
bike accident
no that was the the homestead that was
no homestead testing crash
um that really really messed my brain up
and
i was i took a lot out of me to get back
from and then i broke my back on the
bike
yeah so i just needed some a change of
scenery i think it was a new challenge i
thought
um those crashes um it's funny with the
did you see the roman grosjean crash in
formula one
the other day when he went through the
battery no i didn't
oh he talked about he got stuck and went
through the barrier right through the
armco
he talks about it um and it resonated i
tried to switch it off because it
actually resonated quite a lot there was
that moment
when you talk about that flip with dan
is the car of an
airborne and i thought oh
[ __ ] oh
and it went quiet i thought
am i going to die and it literally was
i think i don't want to die and
it's if the car hits the fence i'm
probably gonna die
i hope it doesn't hurt
and i opened i was very quiet and i
opened my eyes and there was these cars
going underneath me about 20 feet below
and i thought
oh it's not over
people closed my eyes again the car
landed
and it landed on top of scott and we
almost bashed heads had we bashed heads
we'd both been
gone we almost bashed heads and it was
no harder than
falling down running just minimal impact
and i started laughing i was upside down
sliding the line i started laughing
because i'm alive it doesn't hurt
and then the roll bar snapped off my
head started dragging across the ground
it's getting closer
exactly and um
and then i remember that nobody wanted
to turn the car over and sam hornish
came and helped the medical crew
to turn the car over yeah and and doc
trammell was as high as it was she
because they thought that
you know the the accident would be bad
anyway the next day
i was flying um i should finish that
with mom and dad mum and dad were
both at that race and i saw him in the
medical center my dad looked about 100
years old
and i just thought i've got to stop
doing this to my parents
the next day i was flying home in the
helicopter and i landed in newcastle
indiana and i'd landed on the way up for
fuel and i pulled in and they landed
and the whole guy comes out and he goes
well son it was a much smoother landing
than you had yesterday i just heard the
i just heard the fear for your daughters
ever racing right there
because you just said i've got to stop
doing this to my parents and you don't
want your kids to do that to you
yeah you could be right i'm fine
i was fine doing it myself yeah i hate
watching other people
that i or my friends and people i love
hate watching racing
um not because of getting hurt that's
another whole level of sort of scared
but just
because i want them to do well and all
those sort of things
yeah so had i i was i
totally thought going to nascar had to
do with crashing and just going you know
what
give me a roof yeah no and i was
i was gung-ho the next week and i went
back to kentucky
and we had to fly next week six days
later
oh my god and i was like this is this is
not good did you feel like you were
getting a sign like
dario it's time for a time for a change
you know i i
at that point the championship was kind
of getting to that
the end and i knew and i wanted to win
it and i didn't care
what signs or nothing i just went home
and i went testing the next week to
sonoma
was very scary actually to get back in
the car was very scary and then we did a
the last race of the season every time
i would turn into a corner i was worried
someone was there even with the spotter
dave my spotter was telling me they were
clear and i was it was
that that was one of those basically
lying to myself mind over matter
getting the just doing the job and ended
up in the
championship
so why then why nascar so you wanted a
challenge
i wanted the challenge um and you went
in blindly
and i've never been to i've been to one
test i think
i think i'd been to a test day it was
sat in the car
did you ever think f1 well the f1 thing
i had the chance of 97 2000 and
it just never worked out with the
indycar thing you know and so
rather gone to formula one over nascar
if that was an option
oh yeah oh oh absolutely
absolutely but so the nascar thing i did
um
as we did we had to go and do arca races
and i
didn't my first race was in um talladega
in this arc car with the steering wheel
was like like a truck wheel
and i leave the pits and
i hadn't got past second gear and i just
thought um i remember clearly
what have i done yeah i've heard you say
i've seen that written i've seen that
before
yeah and i just i never got a buzz out
of it
so it was the car then you just hated
the car like it it does handle like [ __ ]
i mean it's a boat dreadful things but
our cars were very good
um you know and i was i was under you
but you as you
very well know you're under a lot of
know pressure a lot of my you're under
the microscope
and yeah i started to figure out the
nationwide car a bit or
xfinity i think it's called now um but
the cop cars
were never never very good i broke my
ankle
in an accident
that one hurt and i
i just didn't get a buzz and i was
wanted to
i wanted to do it but i was convinced i
wasn't going back to indycar i remember
that i was not going to do indycar
but once i committed to nascar not doing
indycar
and then i'd gone to detroit and
i watched an indycar go through the
first couple of corners of the detroit
in life
and yeah then the rest is it's history
do you think that you because you went
back to indycar in 2009
and just cleaned up i mean you you
you had the vast majority of your
big records after so it
leads me to wonder if you feel like
what did you get from that it
may have seemed like a detour
however i'm thinking it wasn't and i'm
wondering what it is that you got from
nascar that put you in this
position in 2009 to do what you did
through
2012 before you had your accident
well what what did you say earlier that
you learn from the the hard base really
you heard you learn from those bits
where you fall over really and that was
it i learned so much about myself
and determination and um i've
been out of my comfort zone that when i
got back to indycar and i wanted
i had something to prove too
but um yeah i've been so far at my
comfort zone and
you know from working with me i like the
car very certain way
dude you like your head pad to be within
a 64th of an
inch is probably where you draw the line
but an eighth is definitely a change and
there's a tenth in it
absolutely everything had to be perfect
but
when i came back from that school the
seat still had to be perfect
but i could drive a car that i wasn't
comfortable with
and then that was from doing that and it
was like right okay
look out here we go and i got teamed up
with
a bunch of people who were equally as
uh as hungry to him and when that
happens it's
as you know it's magical
and i went in there literally thinking
if i don't embarrass myself i'll be
happy i just don't want to embarrass
myself against
scott because he was at the top of his
game and it worked out quite well
yeah i'd say and now scott embarrasses
everyone else so he's just
winning everything god
he's do you know when you decided you
were going to retire
yeah you know you it probably looks like
you had
there was a time you could feel your
desire to do it
just tailing off yeah
yeah it's not you just it's a very
subtle change but you feel it
he doesn't get that he's four he's just
turned 40
and he's just just keeps going he might
as well be 30.
exactly i mean his attitude is every day
he just doesn't have that sort of
you know doesn't the the trappings of
his success whatever hasn't slowed him
down
he's still like yesterday i spoke to him
and he was
out in the morning training out running
in the afternoon
just and he's still as committed as ever
to
to success and it is so and i would
definitely draw the parallel
uh in the racing world of dixie
to jimmy right they're both kind of
more i mean let's be lovingly honest
they're both a little bit more sort of
like
quiet vanilla would be usually a word to
describe them
um i mean we know them we know jimmy
we know scott like in certain
environments they're not like that at
all
but you know when it comes to work and
and you know they could be
there but they've both accomplished such
a tremendous
amount like there there's nothing quiet
about their history
and what they've made um so
now you've got jimmy i mean and by the
way what is it what is it
you're i wrote it down your you're
competition director
is that your no no no no no no no
um we kept trying to come up with a
title chip's like what we're going to
call you
and we still haven't uh what do you do
like what do you do then
whatever whatever i can do to make the
team more successful and that's working
with the drivers
um i've actually listened to you
sometimes
sometimes um whether that's hiring you
drivers i interrupted you go ahead yeah
working with the drivers on performance
at the track working with the engineers
how
helping to hire engineers so i think
that guy's good
why do you think you know and that's
great having doug ducat mike hull
as well as chip because those guys all
sort of listen but i think we need to go
after
this driver if and so that that side of
things as well as just the day-to-day
working with um
with working with the guys you know with
with jimmy
he's full-on is awesome he's the
he's got the mindset of a seven-time
champion
with the inquisitive nature of a rookie
he's he's at homestead today running a
formula three car
one of the funniest things i feel like i
heard it was
this is 2000 and i don't remember what
year it was
16 maybe or something like that it was
before the chase
and so it was a big party in chicago
before the chase round the last 10 races
of the nascar season and
we're all going out and um at this point
uh so this is the first year ricky made
the chase
and so i was i think he was in it
maybe it was just because i had a place
in chicago but we were out with all of
them
and we ended up back at my
place in chicago all of us and we're
drinking and having fun and
jeff says the funniest thing he's like
you know in my career
i just didn't really have to try and
like it just kind of happened and he's
like
jimmy works so hard
and i was like did you just say that
um but it kind of goes in line with what
you just said which is the inquisitive
inquisitive nature of a rookie like like
some
people just seek information and want to
consume and are
curious and they uh it's part of their
experience where then there's other
people i guess like jeff and when i say
jeff or anybody like jeff gordon and
jimmy johnson
um jeff like obviously you know you know
jeff too like just
fly by the seat of your pants like have
fun
go for it you know jimmy is like a
student
yeah scott's more that sort of just it
just happens you know
he's chatting to you one minute and or
he's
the thing at the track always amazes me
about scotty's and this is what i
couldn't do and this is why i
couldn't have kids when i was driving
you know
caught five years ago he's got poppy
here tilly here
and they're climbing all over him he's
like right girls give him a kiss gotta
go
get us in the car
and if that's me i'm i'm in the
bus an hour before mentally preparing
and
you know clearing my brain and all this
stuff and i
so that i i get jimmy's sort of that
work ethic and as i got older i realized
i had to work hard and those times i
probably may have been a little bit lazy
in the early years so what how do you
think he's gonna do an indycar is a
beast let's just talk for a second
because you and i can both speak the
language of what's a nascar what's a cup
car like what's a stock car like
and what's an indy car like so from your
experience
what is he about to step into knowing
like telling us a little bit about what
they feel like and then
how the hell is he going to do this his
his biggest thing is going to be
that there's a half a second between
first and last
if you're if you're a half a second off
your last that's going to be difficult
um you know he's got two more test days
in the indycar before the first race in
cmp
he's never driven on the street sorry
where is he testing it
um we've got
a test at sebring good old scenery
another one at laguna we've done two
days so far with them barbar
and laguna two tracks with no runoff and
that was this go fast right and that's
his introduction to indycar so
physically he's got no problem 150 laps
so we're gonna no problem
i mean and by the way stock cars are a
lot physically easier to drive than an
indy car
a lot absolutely but this guy's just a
machine he just loves working out which
i wasn't that much of a big fan i did it
so you know
i didn't want to be tired during the
race but he uh
yeah he's a different level he's in that
sort of dixon and tony i like to work
out thing
which i forgot i do it now
i love you well i see that on your
instagram and stuff i just work out so i
don't have to buy you know jeans with a
bigger waist
yeah exactly you said the half a second
and i get that but what is it about that
half a second that's going to be hard
well and this is something him and i
have talked about we're sitting
i think it laguna
it was one of those comments like jeff
and you went i can kind of figure out
why you sucked so badly now in a cop car
sometimes honestly just comes in a
dagger and you're like okay
so what was it it's the way you know
all the speed that i had especially on
the street mode course
came from entry to apex running that
speed and using the downforce
running bleeding off the brakes running
in that's the area jimmy's been
struggling with so far
because he's always thinking about
getting to the throttle first
and the way he shapes the corner and all
those things which is exactly what you
don't
want to do in an indy car
what i did you don't want to do in a cup
car so we're sort of
we're comparing notes and that's been i
think it's been helpful to know that i
can relate to
i'm driving you know a stock car
and um you know no matter how badly i
did it i can relate to the
what is going to have to do the entry is
so much different than a stock car
versus an indy car
you know the arc of an indy car versus
the shallow entry of a stock car because
you want to load it up slowly like
they're just very different yeah so
that's been that's been
it's been interesting and that's going
to be that whole season it's going to be
a lot of fun and we've got obviously
scott marcus erickson and alex
young spanish kid so polite
he's so but he's badass
he's so quick he's a kid right he's a
kid
how old is he 21 i don't know
i mean of course he's polite because
we're all
ancient compared to him
he hasn't called me sir yet but we're
you know
well that comes in the nascar world
you're gonna hear that maybe jimmy will
drop
that every now and again yes sir his
sponsor does
earl big girl yes ma'am no sir
so how do you think he's gonna do i mean
to me when i hear a half a second what
i'm hearing is um
that you're gonna have to get that good
you're just gonna have to get that good
you know like and and that you know
it's uh to even get within that half a
second is gonna be a lot
to learn to trust the car can do as much
as it can do
um is is a feat because they are extreme
when i jump back in the indy car for the
500 a couple years ago when i did it and
i took off out of the pits
i was like oh [ __ ] i was like oh my
god i was like this is and then the
steering was so heavy and i was like i
can't freaking turn the wheel
and i was like oh my god these things
have so much more power and i was like i
forgot how tight the belts have to be
i truly forgot how tight the belts had
to be do you remember that scene in star
wars when the millennium falcon goes to
hyperdrive
no really deeply come on i haven't seen
star wars
so bad i should have i'm super into
space and
you know you watch star wars it's
awesome but there's this scene where it
just goes
and everything just comes at you warp
factor speed nice
yeah that has to drive my name did he
ever mention anything about the
acceleration
oh yeah yeah acceleration the speed of
of
the the you know the processing
information that he's had to do
he's going to be fine this guy's got i
mean it's an easy thing to say
for a seven time champion he's got so
much talent so much work ethic but
there's going to be
difficult days too because he doesn't
know how to gain time
um at the moment doesn't understand the
intricacies of how a
tire goes off throughout the run how
does the balance change all the little
details that make the difference
between you know winning and finishing
p10 so
um but it's a two-year project and he um
he will surprise a few people and i'm
looking forward to that
how close has he gotten lap time-wise
um
well again we've done two days testing
with him so
i think he was looking for the second
and a half i think it was the second
half around laguna but he got in the f3
car and he was about
that to start off and by the end of the
day he was as quick as anybody
really what yeah his engineer eric said
he said by the end of the day all the
other teams had come out to the pit wall
with the stopwatches
i took that is a good sign
[Music]
why is he doing it did he tell you that
why is he doing it why is he
oh he this guy he loves a challenge it's
just
the same thing you guys speak the same
language yeah
yeah exactly it's apart from he gets he
challenges himself by riding bicycles up
mountains and stuff and
[Music]
come on you rode bikes a little for a
while yeah i still do a bit but i'm sort
of
again it's just vanity notes looking fat
basket on the front
that's going down going down to the
market for a baguette
precisely yeah so then what's the uh
like you know you talked about kind of
you know there being a difference to
being retired and
sometimes more stresses so but what's
the best part
no right no i didn't want to retire
i had all these plans to go racing them
all with porsche and
um then
when it's when it happened
i i wasn't sort of
i remember lying in bed not obviously
not long after but probably
a month after when i can start to
remember things and i wasn't sort of who
was me
i was thinking i can go down that road
but i'm not gonna
think of all the things i got to do all
the the braces i won
i never thought i'd got to win um and i
was just happy to be alive
i mean at that point i was absolutely
like wow
i can go live the rest of my life um
you know i might limp a bit and forget
stuff but
i'm alive so i didn't miss
any of it um and to be honest i don't
miss the high
pressure of racing an indy car
like if they said to me you can go do it
tomorrow i wouldn't do it
um but racing i get to race all cars at
goodwin some really
leery stuff and it's that
floats my boat but i go as fast as i
want to go if you could get back into a
car
at any car at all any race
and you'd be it'd be like 2012 let's say
that that's your that's your sort of
sharpness
which one would you do which
car which truck yeah
i've got a picture of it here it's my 90
my 98 surface paradise winning car which
i have in scotland
um that to me was a perfect thing of
massive horsepower sticky tires
um it was a fun time in life as well
before greg
died and you know we were kids that was
fun so that was
that car probably wrote america
that thing hopped the mail around road
america
i mean it's so it was so quick so
probably probably that car
um i'm partial to my
2010 winner around indy
that was the most dominant car i've ever
had of any
any recent time so i'd like how we spin
in that one again
chip's got that yeah
yeah what about you oh
come on i don't care i'm not in the race
i'm not into cars
i know that sounds like i've had a hard
time admitting that because it sounds
like i cheated the system
but what i loved about racing wasn't the
cars and sort of like it was the
challenge it was setting a goal and
achieving it
it was the journey it was sort of like
the i love the attention to detail the
focus on
on perfecting the race and maybe you can
relate to that because you're quite the
perfectionist but like just like
nailing everything and the feeling of
like threading the needle
and just doing it qualifying and like
letting that and it flowed so well and
you just
you know you nailed it you like floated
it through the whole thing and you're
just like
yeah i just i killed it right
that feeling's amazing and so i loved
that i loved setting a goal and
achieving it but like
racing itself um
i just it wasn't i didn't i can
sort of achieve some of these aspects
about racing in other ways
but if i'm going to give an answer if i
could go
well i could do any race any car
i mean i'd probably go back to that
first indy 500 because it was so good
this car was so good i mean we trimmed
to make it go to make it more balanced
like it was so good
and i was so young with such um
immaturity uh and i
you know would have been i wish i could
have my talent at the end
then um i know what you mean but then on
the same level ignorance is bliss and so
i think there were certain aspects that
because i was so new to it that i didn't
think about
including the charge of the indy 500 the
emotional charge
right because it's like actually as time
goes by it almost starts feeling
more nervous in a way because you can
just like you appreciate
respect and honor the gravity of the
race and the situation and what it does
for your career
what it can do and so it's like i also
didn't have that sort of fear charge but
not going well because i was so new
that makes a lot of sense to me the indy
500 is the only thing i've done in my
life
the more i've done it the more it meant
to me most things you become
more sort of used to not bored with
that's the wrong thing but you become
almost a bit numb to them
even if it's jumping out of an airplane
yeah you're like i've done it five times
indeed i slept less and less every year
i
focused harder i worked harder um
but that that to me especially now and
you'll get to
experience it now doing the tv stuff
there the pre-race
when they sing back home again in
indiana all that stuff that we couldn't
allow ourselves to enjoy as drivers
yeah i get goosebumps thinking about
that was that to me
i love that place and i love that event
um
it's yeah it's so special
yeah what have you um is there anything
now
after racing's over with that you have
realized about yourself
or like a hobby you've taken up or
something like that that you're like
wow i had no idea
i'm so predictable no i mean
my car is all about cars
old cars street cars racing cars
books on cars all these magazines on
cars
um so that is it's just such a big part
of
my my life um
[Music]
you know to me my hobby
is you know get to do all these fun
things around the world different jobs
um i'm getting to work with gordon
murray who did the mclaren f1
he's doing a new cart and working with
him on his new car which is just
it's like every day he's going to school
with this guy like designing
no i'm i'm sort of helping develop and
all these different
parts of this this journey
it's so much fun so get to do that and
that's that to me feels like a hobby
what has been uh your greatest lesson
through all of your experiences because
there have been so many ups and downs i
mean you've really lived quite the
roller coaster with
injuries deaths uh accomplishments
relationships children like
what has been the thing that you would
say
that has been your greatest lesson so
far
that's put you in the place of being so
happy now
i don't think it's one lesson it's not
one thing that changed
it's a lifetime of experience um
and the people i've been exposed to
[Music]
you know whether that was people i
worked with whether that was being
married
actually whether you know um
[Music]
all these great people have been exposed
to and how they they sort of
they shaped um you know my parents
before that
um and from every person and every
every experience i've had good and bad
of i think i've learned something
um and i think
that that i think age gives you
some perspective as well because of
those those experiences
well then let me say let me ask this in
another way then
what is an experience that was so
horrible
that you can look back now and say
i know that i wasn't in a good place
about it then but i look back now
and i'm so glad that happened to me
i wouldn't say horrible experience but
the nascar experience i was
always from the moment from the moment i
left i was always happy that
i've done it um
[Music]
the the crashes the injuries all that
stuff i really didn't
and don't those weren't
those weren't fun um do you
you were along on the same ride losing
friends
that's you know that's hard to sit here
with with
with sofia and you know there's
a picture of greg just over there and
sort of talk about her uncle greg and
you know he was daddy's friend and all
that sort of stuff that's great
that's quite tough value life living to
the fullest
and say yes sir i have a question for
you and this is something
we you talked about being a
perfectionist
um and our band was the ultimate
perfectionist right
i mean every you know his perfect shoes
and his
you know you have to tell the story
about
what you did to him in i think it was
japan
you have to try that story for his level
of because he was like a germaphobish
clean freak too he was until until
him and susie had the boys right but
this happened before
what did you and the boys do to him okay
so
2004
2004. we got japan and
we stayed in that hotel they would
always give us the team i don't know if
you knew this but the teams always end
up with hotel rooms all in a line
so you'd end up next okay yes so you
didn't want to be next to tony because
he snored really badly
and you could hear him through the wall
anyway
we decided hearthstone was always the
instigator and brian's like i'm gonna do
oh i know dan's going to the honda
museum
so well let's go in his room and mess it
up
okay so tony goes downstairs he's like
hello
dan weldon gonna have his key please
there's key
i'll pick the wrench we go in we took
one of every shoe and then
traveled down 20 pairs of shoes um
one of their issue we took the tv away
we took all this hair care and skin
products and we poured them in the
bathtub
um we also messed up the bathroom a
little in another way but i'm not going
to go into that um
and we turned the heat up full
i guess is it called dragon is it dry
docking is that what they call it
sure we did that and then we turned the
heat up full
um we closed the door
and we sat in the next room
and we're live oh here he comes here he
comes here he comes
and sedan comes up you know mr ocd
everything's perfect all the
the everything's laid out in bed
perfectly in the closet and
lined up and he heard him
opens the door he's like mother
yeah he he went apoplectic
he was he got one of the bosses he's
like you're gonna
you make these guys do this right we've
already sent the shoes
the shoes had all um disappeared i think
one of each had to go back to the us
um he was so mad he got the last lap
because he won his first race that
weekend but
he was he was beyond
anyway so i love that that's so funny
you guys played because you guys became
the tricksters and i always got asked
like what did they do to you did they
like
haze you in any way i'm like i'm not
sure they knew what to do with me
now we were too scared of me or doing
the wrong
thing because i'm a scary person the
worst one i did was like hacksaw tony's
bike in half
yeah that's pretty mean because it was
probably like seven thousand dollar bike
or something it was a lot of money
um yeah he was on live on tv and i stood
behind the camera with a hacksaw
while he was on the show it was
brilliant um
didn't speak a perfectionistic question
perfection so dan
was the ultimate perfectionist you said
about being a perfectionist have you
found that has
both positively negatively bled into
your life
your everyday life yeah yeah of course
any
extreme of anything is going to have a
negative
effect um there are some aspects
of a personality that you know if
i were to choose i'd be like well i'm
glad i got that one
in extreme versus the other side of the
extreme
um and so with perfection being a
perfectionist
um i i would say that it's
has more benefits than being a slob
and not caring um
but it can also uh be
a waste of energy because it doesn't
matter right so it's a matter of sort of
and anytime you're trying to break a
pattern or addiction of something it
is that hard it is is if you are
addicted and so the
you have to train yourself to stop
caring about little things
and it's always going to be
uncomfortable and then as you do it more
and more then
you come more into balance and then you
don't it doesn't have to be
your way and a certain way um
yeah so uh yeah i see it show up and
yeah so one more question yeah
so when we were like when we were
teammates when we were racing together
and stuff
were you always sort of this
deep thinking or is this a new
thing is this replaced um because you're
you're pretty deep now you know you
really think about things which is
phenomenal
but is this a new phenomenon
no i am
i've been doing a lot of talking about
this aspect of myself
and actually within the last 24 hours
and i used to do a lot where it would be
mental and outside of me and
the journey is inside of me now and so
i put a lot of effort into the outside
and i got a lot as a result but it can't
take me all the way to where i want to
go
or where i could go by continuing with
the external
the journey has to go inward and that is
a
expansive space of potential um
and and information versus trying to
learn it here in this
linear world this is not so linear this
is vertical
that's horizontal that's linear and
so so yeah i remember when i was a young
kid like i would go to the bookstore
once i could drive and i would always go
to the self-help section
and i was pulling books that were
self-help and i didn't read a lot of
books and i know you'd love to read
um because because they were heavy like
i remember reading one when i was a kid
that was about like peeling away an
onion someone that went into solitary
like into solitude
with no one not speaking to anyone and
and i don't remember a ton about the
book other than that and that
the analogy that kept getting used in
this book was peeling away the layers to
getting to the core of who they were
and like that's the kind of stuff i was
reading i mean i was getting like
astrology and and and psychic readings
when i was a teenager because i was
curious
i mean i didn't know any of this now i
speak to guides and akashic readers on a
regular basis like i'm so
curious and you know i'm so curious
about the quantum the unknown the unseen
and guess what i'm realizing is that the
journey is quite inward
it's not something intellectual it's
something felt and i think maybe that's
the magic of kids too in a way like
it's not something that you can go it's
a feeling
it's probably indescribable almost
yeah the love the connection the
care and so um
yeah i've always been like this though i
just didn't get to
and so in the end actually what happened
was i started really feeding into this
sort of aspect of myself
more um like 2000 i suppose it started
in like 14 or 15
a lot and then from that point on once
17
came i and my main sponsor left at the
beginning of the year which was a weird
scenario that i had never been faced
with
um this idea of being done came about
and i still had that year and another
year on my contract and i had
no intentions of retiring and even after
that i hadn't i mean hadn't even had
thoughts of it and so
um i kind of started
falling out of resonance with my
environment
and you start recognizing how kind of
unhappy a lot of people are
and then you start recognizing the
dynamic energetically that it took to be
successful and a lot of times you had to
be
pretty big [ __ ] and you know that
that selfishness and everything
that was and so i had that right i've
lived that
and but it it it became something that
wasn't as embodied in me anymore and i
was sort of
shifting and so i just kind of fell out
of resonance and so
um it's always been in me it's just
there was never
it was just about the time right i just
i had to go through my own phases which
is why
you know maybe sophia is going to be a
race car driver and
you know maybe she'll be all in like dad
was and
like anyone who's great at somebody at
something and then
she'll learn her own way but sometimes
it's kind of like you going to nascar
it's like you might have seen it as a
sidestep but
i think it had a lot to do with your
continued and
and expanding ex
you know ex records and win
i think it was part of it so it might
have seemed like a sidetrack but it's
all part of the journey it's actually
how you get to the greatest result so
sometimes you have to be out of balance
to learn a lesson to get to where you
need to go
deep deep deep
thank you dp thank you that was fun
that was fun you're the best hope you
enjoyed
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button